what's your female-to-male ratio do you
know it started as 50/50 I think it's a
little more women now but I don't know
exactly
this show is ninety-nine point eight
guys I'll do every show I open it up
without your whoop it's a real [ __ ] bros
nobody likes the smell a morning dick I
know it's like talking you but it's like
funny to say it's big get sweaty at
night usually naked I know I feel a
little welcome you do yeah so I get
scared a spider something is gonna crawl
up where it shouldn't spiders gonna cry
over China if you had a vagina I would
you not be scared about it spider can
crawl on my dick your dick hole just is
how likely is your job we call them we
don't know like this like this no spider
crawling your vagina it scared me I'm
obviously making yes sometimes what are
you wearing just my undies just your I'm
old-school I wear the whitey tighties
still okay but is that true that
uncircumcised dick smell more than
normal day I know you know a lot of
uncircumcised dicks and they don't smell
it no what do you mean they smell good
friend of mine works in the ER and he
they had a guy that came in who was in
his 30s and he was uncircumcised yeah
and they were like he was I call this
such such pain there's such pain such
pain and so they go to check him out and
he's looking at him and he's like I
can't really see what's going on but
then he's looking and he pulls back the
sleeve he pulls back his sleeve and it's
like a doughnuts a mini doughnut size
ring of like smegma build up Oh like
never washed asleep he never cleaned
under the lettuce leaves it's a wizard
sleeve Oh
Alex urgently take it off and shouldn't
and the guy was in such pain he was
crying they said he passed out a few
times I would pass got a pain your
sleeve got a fine under the sheets your
wee little shoes oh yeah so they can be
stinkier than usual never washes his
dick but a normal thank you the extreme
case yeah this is the one this is the
guy we're just getting right into it I
also hear sorry
I also heard and I wouldn't know but the
guys who have the hoods it feels better
like sex what's to compare how would
they know that it feels better than what
you wicks more could you cut nerves mmm
no did you circumcised later in life we
need to ask them well better when you
stick the head in when you stick the tip
in does it feel good yeah but yeah
that's it guy with the hood he might be
like you're at a nine I'm at a 10 how do
you know how would we know I don't know
we don't know we'll never know that's
why I don't think I don't believe in
that give that to you as it's a gift
it's a gift it's a gift